I tried recording this possible
solution to the
bailout video just now, but
apparently the sound went bad
so I just restarted my computer,
so hopefully I won't
turn into slow motion
man again.
Well, anyway, the whole
discussion so far has been
focused on how did the credit
crisis get started, and why
the card bailout proposal,
one, is wrong from just a
moral hazard and fairness point
of view, and why it
probably won't work even
to begin with.
So, you know, why
even go into it?
And some of you all said, well,
what could be a solution?
And I've argued a little bit
in the wealth destruction
video that you really can't
legislate against reality.
That you kind of have to
let things correct.
You cannot create wealth
just by passing bills.
All you can kind of do
is shuffle around
who takes the losses.
But in one of the videos, I
argued that if the government
was serious about helping Main
Street, about loans to Main
Street, why don't they lend
directly to Main Street?
And I kind of said it a little
bit flippantly that if that
was their intention, that's what
they should do with the
$700 billion.
And I got an email from a friend
from business school, a
very intelligent fellow who I
respect very much, and he has
a solution that I think
is essentially that.
Loan directly to Main Street.
Don't bail out these people
who have already acted
extremely irresponsibly and
essentially write them checks
from American taxpayers.
And his suggestion is, instead
of buying worthless assets,
why not create new banks fully
capitalized by the
government-- but you might not
even have to capitalize them--
and let those banks lend
directly to Main Street?
And he makes a very
interesting point.
He says -- let me make sure that
I can fit all of this.
And I don't know if
you can read it.
I want this to all fit.
But he makes the interesting
point.
$700 billion of capital -- this
is his email that he sent
to me -- with $700 billion of
equity, this is more book
equity, and therefore more
lending power, than Bank of
America, J.P.
Morgan, Citigroup, Washington
Mutual, Wachovia, Goldman
Sachs, and Morgan Stanley
combined.
So combine these institutions,
which are really the pillars
of our financial system,
they represent $619
billion of book equity.
And remember, this is
their book equity.
This is what they say is the
book value of their assets.
But we've already learned that
they're probably being
overstated, and that's why we
have to go and buy them at
prices more than what
they're worth.
But this -- just to get an idea
how large of a dollar
amount this is -- this $700
billion is more than what
these banks say they're worth.
It's probably several
multiples of what
they really are worth.
Some of these banks probably
aren't worth anything.
And as it points out, the new
bank would have no prior
committed loans, so the
incremental amount of lending
available would be
much larger.
Which means you are not lending
into a black hole.
When you lend money or you
essentially give money to one
of these banks that have
all of these other bad
liabilities, your money's
essentially just being poured
into a black hole and there's no
assurance that that bank is
going to go and then lend that
money to other people, and go
to main street.
But if you inject it into
a bank with a completely
pristine balance sheet, a new
bank -- you could call it you
know the Bank of Washington,
the Bank of Jefferson.
And I would actually recommend
having multiple banks, just so
you have competition and you
don't have that too big to
fail problem.
But these banks, they would have
pristine balance sheets,
and they would go out and make
loans, and they would go out
and make loans wherever
it is most prudent.
And he says, you know, this
accomplishes the goal of
injecting lending capital into
the system without creating
the moral hazard problem, and at
the end of a few years, the
government will probably be able
to IPO sell the bank for
more than one times book value,
which will include the
original $700 billion,
generating a substantial
profit to the taxpayer.
Exactly.
In fact, they could either do
that, the government could own
it and then try to IPO it in
five years or so, like Todd
suggests, or another option is
maybe each of these banks--
maybe the bank takes $700
billion and creates 10 banks
that each have $70 billion in
initial equity capital.
And maybe the government issues
300 million shares of
each of those banks, and every
American man, woman, and child
gets one share of each
of those banks.
I think that would have a very
powerful political statement.
And it actually would
make economic sense.
All of a sudden you would have
the American people are now
the owners of the banking
system, instead of this
concentrated wealth that's
really formed over the past
150 years in the old
banking system.
And then, you know, he
goes on to point
out some other things.
Sure, the more current banks
would fail probably quicker,
and we all know that's
a good thing.
What happened in Japan?
What happened in Japan is we
kept infusing capital into--
well, we didn't, the Japanese
government kept infusing-- or
either did it themselves or
coaxed other people to infuse
capital into banks that were
essentially zombie banks, that
were insolvent, and
just slowed down.
It slowed down the downfall, and
essentially led to their
lost decade.
So he says, you know, more banks
would fail, but many of
them probably would be deserve
to fail, and the financial
system would be preserved.
I agree with him completely.
If the new bank wants to
lend new money to new
borrowers, it can.
Or if it thinks it will make
more money buying up old
loans, like the CDOs or the
residential mortgage backed
securities, at a deep discount,
it can do this too.
But it will be making a clear
economic profit decision.
And I'd add-- just so that we
make sure that the management
of these new entities, so that
they are aligned with
profit-making as opposed to
bailing out their own previous
past bad decisions, or bailing
out the people who they used
to work with-- I would
try to not put these
banks in New York.
Maybe you put them in Detroit
and New Orleans and Stockton,
California, which is the
foreclosure capital of the
world, of the country.
Put them in places that are
separate from Wall Street.
Hire very intelligent people
who have some distance from
what has happened the last five,
six years in Michigan.
And I'll tell you, there are
tons and tons of very
competent, very intelligent
managers who understand these
issues deeply in this country.
Unfortunately, a lot of
them haven't been
heads of banks lately.
And they would be happy to work
for something less than
$20 million a year.
In fact, I think many of
them would do it out
of patriotic duty.
But you could pay them $100
thousand a year, and then you
could say, you know what?
You, as the new employees of
these new American banks that
are owned by the American
people-- and they can be
traded on an exchange, so it's
essentially immediately
privatized.
It's never owned by
the government.
It's immediately owned by the
private sector, by the
American people, not
by the government.
When I say American people,
it's literally owned by
private individuals, not
by the government.
But you can actually create an
incentive structure, that
whatever the equity value of
your company is five years
out, you all, as the employees,
share 1% of the benefit.
And that's actually a huge
number, that actually
might be too much.
But you'll be able to hire
excellent managers, especially
considering how many people
are getting laid off right
now, very intelligent people
because of bad, risky
decisions made by others.
But then he finishes up, I
recognize this will be less
politically popular among
banking lobbyists, but see it
as a much better way to, one,
protect the financial system--
I agree with him completely--
two, minimize the risk,
maximize the reward to
the U.S. government.
And he welcomes any comments,
criticisms. And I think it's
interesting, he started off
the idea, he says, "The
problem is this sort of plan
would be political suicide,
with key financial donors to
political campaigns." And
that's true.
Unfortunately-- I think this
is a good idea, but I think
the current old banking system
has a much more receptive ear
of our government unfortunately,
than I, or
Todd, or frankly the American
people seem to have right now.
But anyway, I was kind of
parsing Todd's email.
Let me actually draw out a plan
of what this would be.
So you take $700 billion-- and
let me write that out-- 700,
that's thousand, that's million,
that's billion.
You take that $700 billion,
and you-- I don't know, I
think the more banks
the better.
You want competition.
You don't want to have this
too big to fail problem.
So you take that $700 billion,
and the first time I recorded
this video, I said you
put it in 10 banks.
But, I don't know, let's put it
in-- let's see, 700 divided
by 10 banks would be
$70 billion each.
If you do what?
If you do 70 banks, you would
have $10 billion each.
So let's do that.
Put it in 70 different banks.
70 different banks.
Or maybe do it in 50 different
banks, one bank for each state
of the country.
70 different banks.
I mean, that sounds crazy, but
when you think about what the
government was originally--
Actually, let's do 50 banks.
I like the sound of that.
One bank in every
state, right?
And they're not all concentrated
in New York, and
they're not, you know, so
you get fresh thought,
fresh blood in them.
And they might actually hire
people that are getting laid
off in the manufacturing sector
or the real estate
sector or whatever.
You take 50 different banks.
You capitalize them
each with what?
50 goes into 700 billion
14 times?
Right.
14, let's see, 15 -- right,
goes in 14 times.
So you capitalize them each
with $14 billion, so their
balance sheets are going
to look like this.
Equity-- this is each bank-- $14
billion of initial equity.
And they're going to have
300 million shares,
one for every American.
And if they don't like
the holding shares,
they can sell them.
They'll all IPO on
the exchanges.
And then these will be member
banks of the Fed.
And so they'll be regulated,
but they can
lever up 10 to one.
So they can, let's say with $14
billion of assets, each of
these banks can control $100--
with $14 billion of equity,
each of these banks can control
$140 billion of assets.
Which, essentially, that's $140
billion that they can
lend out to the world.
If they see good returns, good
economic investment in Main
Street, they'll do it there.
If they think that some of the
existing banks are actually
good credit risks, that they
could lend maybe to J.P.
Morgan, or Bank of America,
they'll do it.
Maybe they won't do it at 6%
like the Fed wants them to, or
at 2%, or whatever, they'll say
that's a little risky, or
maybe I'll do it
at 10% or 12%.
And this is another side note
I'd like to say, it seems like
the Fed is getting frustrated
that it wants to dictate that
banks have to lend to each
other at 2%, but they're
willing to only lend to
each other at 6%.
And so it's losing control over
that notion of what banks
lend to each other at.
6% is still low.
If I have to lend money to
someone who could go under
next week, I want at
least 12% or 15%.
And I don't think that's
a crazy interest rate.
That's what people were paying
in the early '80s, and they
weren't talking about financial
Armageddon back then.
But anyway, each of these banks
would have $140 billion
in assets, and then-- I don't
know, how much in liability?
Let's see, 140 minus 14 is $124
billion in liabilities.
And they would be very
easy to borrow money.
These banks would have an easy
time borrowing money from a
bunch of different people.
And why is that?
Well, one, they have completely
pristine balance sheets.
No one worries about what kind
of stinky things they have on
this side, because it's
all new investments.
And then if the government
really wants to make sure that
these banks get off the ground
running, they can make them a
temporary government
back stop on it.
So essentially, they could
be government-sponsored
enterprises, but not
indefinitely.
We don't want a Fanny Mae,
Freddie Mac again.
You could say five year
government back stop.
Which essentially says, if you
lend to these banks over the
next five years, anyone lending
to these banks over
the next five years, if for
whatever reason these banks
were to go under you
will be made whole.
So there's literally no risk to
investing in these banks.
And frankly, frankly, if just
this five year government back
stop on these banks, I think
will encourage people to
invest equity in these banks,
and the government might not
even have to put these $14
billion in each bank.
But anyway, I've run
out of time.
I'll continue this in
the next video.